I love the fact that that you had this
amazing lion costume how did you decide
on that costume well in the beginning
when I had one of the first couple
meetings they had you know a bunch of
pictures of all the different costumes
and that one immediately was the first
one I just said look at this thing it's
so cool I'm I just I was immediately
drawn to that one maybe I'm a Leo and so
I just and just all the gold I thought
it looked also super strong and
confident I loved the whole kind of
gladiator vibe of all of it was it a nod
to your like faint cuz you have a big
family was it kind of a nod to your
family and you're strong there's so many
things that people connected to it asked
me if I chose it because of this that
when I picked it I did I didn't even
think about no later I went oh yeah that
makes sense that totally works yeah Nick
Cannon told me that he thought the lion
was the most extravagant costume was the
most expensive looking costume so what
was one secret about it that you could
tell us that maybe the public would have
known about the costume it was so heavy
yeah it was so heavy the mask alone
itself I think was 10 or 12 pounds and
then that huge big fur cape I was
wearing was probably five or six my gosh
you were getting a workout I just wanted
a girl over oh I don't know how you guys
did I have no idea how you kept it so
secret but you did good job I tried it
was hard was it your family no did you
tell your mom and I told my family but
immediately as soon as it started airing
and people on Twitter started guessing
maybe it was me I had everyone was
coming up to me asking and I'm trying
not to lie obviously I just flat-out
lied to people but I can't ruin the
surprise
yeah so I was trying to find a balance
of not giving it away I can't I couldn't
imagine you couldn't have told your
sisters you guys are like so yeah were
they so super proud of you that yeah I
was doing this show something that was
you know kind of important to you that
you that you held close I just thought
it was a crazy idea I when I originally
was sent all the stuff in the promos
about the show that they had done
I just was I was like what what the hood
is this was it in the media yes or were
you like hold on I definitely had to
think about it because I wanted to
figure out is this right for me how are
they gonna do it obviously this show
worked over there but how is it gonna go
over here but at the end of the day I
just thought it was a fun opportunity to
be able to sing without anyone's maybe
prior judgment or and and that's what's
cool about it is it was just solely
based on your talent not about what
people know about you because I think
sometimes just because of the world we
live in that can cloud it even in a
positive manner or in a negative way
okay so here's the part of the interview
where I am the overthinking because I do
feel like that it's a bit of an
emotional journey doing this show and
that reveal is a moment like an exhale
am I wrong
not as much for me because I would have
happily waited a little bit on her to
reveal myself but I was telling my
friends I was like I am happy to be the
Jennifer Hudson we obviously have seen
how well but it was just fun for me
mostly because at the time obviously the
judges had they were so far away and and
I think that was a cool surprise that
just to be able to show them that did
your folks have a favor favorite
performance I don't know I actually
haven't even asked and my favorite was
definitely the Lady Gaga one yeah very
very good um how do you think that your
family would do on this show like your
mom and dad how did that how would they
do I think they were too great my mom's
actually got a great voice and my dad
too I would love to see what my sister
Scout doing cuz she's got an incredible
voice as well did you guys all watch
together did you have like um sometimes
I was mostly just watching later and
then sending them clips or something I
know you said you told your family but
anybody else did you tell anyone I tried
really hard not to because I think
obviously it's it's hard sometimes for
people for things once you it's like
once you tell one person it just goes
everywhere so I tried to really just
keep it to my family how many of the
other content
since did you know and do you think I
had no idea that they wouldn't tell us
no so you still don't I mean you just
know who's been revealed up until now
yeah and and even so say I was in the
studio that day when we were filming
when the person was getting revealed we
weren't allowed to be there to even
watch to see who had been revealed right
because they didn't because the show
wasn't airing it so it was I mean it was
so secretive it was like I felt like I
was in the secrets or did you have an
idea that when you started watching the
show like okay I think that's this
person or I think that's this person who
were you right well the same with you
know how my name kept coming up on
Twitter all the people that so far have
been revealed everyone has been guest
yeah so correctly I mean I I feel like
maybe for next season they're gonna have
to tone down the clues because people
got everyone's exhume flats exactly and
how do you I feel like to next season I
mean it was so hard this year keeping it
how the heck do you keep it so secret I
don't know because that's the thing we
were so secretive already and but no one
knew what we were doing now I have no
idea how they're gonna do it so you
weren't allowed to watch the other
performances and like try to guess or no
no you couldn't see anything and even
when we were backstage to say on a day
that we were shooting and maybe there's
four of us there I'm not allowed to talk
to any of the other instance and so you
and say whoever you brought with you
that day even your family who you
brought had to wear masks and hoodies
and I had to wear a sweatshirt that said
please don't talk to me this big you
know those like bad golf visors that
people wear and it and then I had to put
it over my face I thought I really did
think that you would go further I
thought you might make it to the finale
I really do know well you got a great
voice you really did would you
was that your goal like at least let's
try to get to the finale absolutely and
I was so bummed because I had such a
cool performance for the last one I was
gonna do total eclipse of the heart and
we had this amazing all of these
incredible
cup dancers and have this stage that was
gonna raise up on this thing and so then
they told me that and I just that was
the part that I was the most bummed for
even if I didn't win or make it to the
end I just was bummed that I didn't get
to do that performance cuz I love that
song that song is so it would have been
so cool I wanna shut it all down for
real okay here's what I think they need
to do like remember on American Idol
they would bring people back for the
finale so not everybody knew that you
had such a great voice now will we get
some music from absolutely yeah I'm
working on an album right now and I'm
hoping to have it done by then in the
year that's the goal yeah
did you have people come up to you and
be like holy cow you know of course can
they thought you were like I didn't know
you had such a great voice that's been
the coolest thing is seeing the response
especially on social media of so many
people just being so supportive and and
so excited and going I had no idea you
could sing like that but I'm such a huge
fan now so that was a really cool part
of it and the judges some of the people
they guessed who knew you were a member
of Destiny's Child when they throw out
names and put you in that company I mean
what is that I'm so excited I'm just
staying there silently in my mask just
like mine doesn't an something yeah you
could say Beyonce next yeah um so so if
you you know has anybody liked any of
your celebrity friends said maybe I want
to do it would you like try to encourage
anyone or who do you think of your
friends that would really do well oh man
I don't know I mean I feel like anyone
who maybe isn't necessarily known for
being a singer right away I think would
be really cool because I think sometimes
it's easy if you're known say for being
a singer and people can recognize your
voice but if it's not something that
people necessarily know you for I think
that that would be a really cool thing
to just go and surprise people how did
you rehearse
they just set blocks of time how many
days a week did you do it when you're
when you're prepping for the show well
we shot all in a month
the whole show the whole show was shot
in a month so it was I mean the first
time I ever fully had my costume on and
was able to practice singing was the day
we shot the first episode so it was
definitely a learning experience and
kind of throws you for a loop because I
couldn't see past here on the mask so
and I'm wearing really really tall
almost Gaga boots and so I was just
praying every day that I'm not gonna
feel like your vision literally was just
right there like you couldn't look at me
you forget how much you rely on that
when you're walking forward if you're
taking a step down if I needed to look
down I fully had to tilt my whole entire
head down and I had no peripheral vision
my whole body to try and see would you
like if they said hey remember you want
to come guest judge or Joe would you
wanna show absolutely yeah okay so when
can we expect this music by the way
we're gonna now yeah hopefully hopefully
by the end of the year that's my goal
okay yeah genre well I grew up listening
to a lot of jazz and soul and blues and
definitely got a soulful voice and so I
really want to try and find a way to
integrate that into what I want to do
but in a modern way very along the lines
of kind of how Amy Winehouse did it I
think that she really did such an
incredible job of almost creating her
new a new genre of that kind of music
and so I haven't quite figured out
exactly how I want to bring it out and
honestly wouldn't want to limit myself
by saying oh I'm gonna do pop or I'm
gonna do jazz or whatever it may be and
just kind of see how it ends up
happening well I do need to ask you
because there is news today about a
member of the Empire family and you of
course were on this show when you heard
the news number one that Jesse had been
arrested what did you think about that
and then the subsequent news that
apparently this was orchestrated because
he was dissatisfied with his salary I
mean look I haven't been on the show and
in awhile and almost over a year but I
think for me my immediate reaction was
I'm just
you're just really devastated for
everybody involved I think it's just
it's it's really tough but for me the
most important thing that I hope comes
out of all of this is regardless of the
outcome of this particular situation I
really hope that this doesn't put a
damper on people a willing to stand up
and advocate for victims and for us all
to really continue to rally around the
LGBTQ community and all of that because
I think that that's important not to let
any situation like make people then not
want to speak up or make people not
believe victims I think that that's
that's really my huge takeaway how do
you reconcile this situation when
someone you know you know I'm I'm not in
a place to and I as I don't think anyone
should make make any judgments just yeah
and I just think like I think nobody can
really know what's going on except
what's the person you know and I think
I'm yeah it's just it's a really tough
situation
[Music]